cuando el sol cae en medellín los
proyectores se prenden para alumbrar los
edificios de la que es conocida como la
ciudad de la eterna primavera pero
también en una eterna cuarentena está
este grupo de artistas y cineastas que
gracias a un proyector protestan desde
una terraza con mensajes que reflejan la
mala situación por la que pasa el sector
cultural colombiano en tiempos de kobe
la cultura por el estado no se entiende
como todas estas expresiones que
demuestran un pueblo en la música en la
pintura en el teatro en el cine en una
cantidad de dt
de herramientas cierto más bien ver la
cultura es como entretenimiento todos
los domingos en la noche varias terrazas
se dan cita para manifestar en los muros
de medellín pues por ahora la calle no
es una opción
los mensajes revelan las diferentes
caras de una crisis cultural que ya
estaba instalada en colombia deja ver la
precariedad del mundo artístico la falta
de importancia que le da al estado
a nuestras manifestaciones
y bueno pues ahí estamos un poco
tratando de generar más preguntas y de
generar ahora el sector de la industria
cultural ocupaba más de 70 mil personas
hoy muchos de ellos se enfrentan una
situación que no se esperaban con el
cierre de salas de cine de conciertos
teatros y museos el gobierno entregó
ayudas económicas y algunos mercados
pero la falta de descenso en el sector
artístico no hace posible que todos se
beneficien
la nueva banda de la terraza ya cruzó
fronteras el concepto replicado en
brasil y méxico- y son muchos los
artistas que se han unido a la idea de
hacer activismo o activismo de manera
pacífica